[Music]
I mean I would have liked to use threads
more if it didn't share the same problem
with Twitter which is just show me who I
[__] follow yeah please like as soon
as I saw people I don't follow on my
feed I'm like okay no uh this I actually
had the other problem where it was like
I I was following people but this wasn't
any stuff on the timeline because people
weren't posting that much and I was like
oh this is
at least on Twitter I see some weird
[__] yeah yeah um you know I I know I'm
getting old because I'm just like I miss
the days where if there is just like a
social media platform where I get to
decide what I see and it's not some
[__] algorithm or some [__]
computer deciding hey this is the thing
that's going to interest you the most
you know because you know for a long
time that was my Twitter that was that
was like my Twitter Twitter was like my
safe space of just my safe space of just
like if I want to follow the people I'm
following and what they're getting up to
this is the space yeah and then Elon
took over and now it's just a [__]
quote retweet hell yeah actually I I
tweets that come up that's just [__]
that I should not be seeing yeah Andrew
Taylor and I don't want to see the
Andrew Tate yeah originally I I was I
was making final crash for buying
Twitter blue and then I looked at my
analytics and it was like it was like it
was like up and down up and down and
then it's crazy it literally took a nose
dive after they removed verification
right and like the Tweet just weren't
being pushed to anywhere I tried to get
rid of Twitter blue after a month and it
wouldn't go away
a [__] bear into your house I
shouldn't have let that bear in I was
like well the only reason for such a
cliff dive was that I lost the
verification and so I joined up again to
see if it go back up and sure enough
right after I bought it again went right
back up I was like this is [__] I mean
that's the only reason I use Twitter is
to sort of promote my videos yeah
because YouTube has become increasingly
[__] so I thought get sort of blue at
least it might promote my stuff and not
know I mean it does unfortunately and
that's the sad truth of the matter yeah
but then you see verified accounts here
like this is useless it's [__] like
Twitter is garbage now yeah absolutely
garbage it's well it's gonna be
worthless in five years I think well
that's why I was hoping like threads
would actually kind of take off too you
know replace it but I think Instagram
you're gonna see Instagram get more
popular yeah oh yeah yeah I've actually
tried doing a little bit I saw [__]
this morning you can't post it a [__]
story and I'm like dad's back
what came in look what I got gaming guys
yeah yeah I'll do one with my book wait
I'm gonna get an Instagram story off
gone making an Instagram story but one
day oh yeah there you go
look at this look at this but like even
my YouTube feed uh of contents just it's
just got really weird recently it's all
very odd and like unfortunately I'm just
getting all this viral content that I
don't want to see like white person
speaks Japanese people so what are you
what is that [__] content like you
can do that what do you want to watch it
yeah time I put all this time into my
video when I should be going up to
Japanese people going
and they'll go oh no Uncle does it like
that's not content
this all started from uh what was that
guy experience we spoke Chinese fluently
yeah yeah which and the thing is is that
I think ultimately the reason why I
think there's those Japanese videos
aren't entertaining from General levels
that I think Chinese people are just way
more
in these videos these dudes are like
they'll [__] like flip a table and
Sprint around and go that's true whoa
and then that's why it's kind of but it
doesn't really work in Japan it doesn't
and I I saw a video that like you know
millions millions of years and uh I
clicked I must be good then and it's
literally like oh chicken Tabby Mass
tokuni
it's like tamani it's actually me
you know it's just like the Japanese
I was just like if this is the level
what am I doing with my life if I can
get 20 times the views with 500 times
less effort I am doing something wrong
yeah yeah can can we name this episode
like Asian guy surprises two white men
by speaking English for two hours
it's like you know most people they
don't give a [__] they'll say
there's a few people
and it's I'm not even saying it's their
like I'm angry at them because it's the
algorithm the thing about YouTube you
make one video it kicks off it does
really well you want to make another and
I you know I some people have Day in the
Life videos some people have tiny
apartment videos some people have ice
white person speaks Japanese you know
and there's this YouTube and they they
go on to one yeah and I've never done
that and I wish I probably [__]
should have done it sounds sounds like
you're more Angry almost at yourself
that you didn't take them myself
I think it's just like you know what
videos do well about Japan yeah like
when I'm desperate I have like a break
now an emergency and then the Things
fall on the floor it's like okay ah tiny
apartment oh speak Japanese
or something [__] 24 hours you [__]
know the content you need to make but
you don't but I just feel like I don't
want it well there's a clip of me on
like Hassan's stream where I audited
Starbucks and as you know when you order
a Starbucks hard none of the words of
Japanese yeah yeah they were like the
title was like it's Connor's amazing
Japanese it was like uh cappuccino
and everyone accounts like what the [__]
but can you say cold brew okay
and then they were like oh my God that's
the hardest Japanese word to say
yeah
I can't I I I just I I when I look at it
I'm like I pointed it I'm like I don't
know how to say it cool that's why Conor
can't make uh
[Laughter]
of course I do still enjoy making videos
there and I love my audience I love the
people that watch a porn Japan you know
there's a really good core audience I
don't know what the audience is it's
probably like 800 000 core viewership
that's the most that's a pretty good if
I can make a general I could make a
viral video that I know would go viral
right yeah but I just want to make the
content I want to make it oh that's what
it's all about it seems like you have a
real passion in like filmmaking I do and
I honestly I I love I get excited about
the composition and the color grading
and yeah the least my least favorite bit
is presenting right right I mean you
film like a whole [__] sniper
sequence in the uh
which you know from a YouTube content
perspective absolutely not necessary
yeah it was a bit excessive
just a bit well you know as a content
creator I made that because I want to
watch John Wick 4 and it wasn't out in
Japan and Carl's like what's wrong with
four in Hawaii or something yeah I was
like yeah that was what was powering me
through on the cycle well every day I
was like I'm gonna be in Hawaii next
week watching John Wick four and that
was enough to get me so I was like I
can't watch it I'll make my own job
and that's how that came about yeah God
said something the other day he said he
said what he said uh he watched John
Wick 4 but didn't watch John Wick 3 and
was like oh it's probably not that
important to the story
I mean it kind of is but you can watch
it without saying I don't I don't think
my viewing experience was diminished
that much by missing uh some of the
stories doesn't have much of a story yes
it does yeah I mean is watching John
Wick 3 explain just the lack of any
dialogue that John Wick actually says
yeah
when he says John yeah like it's that's
John work I love that though when he
says yes you get the backstory behind
her yeah yeah